ההצלחה של אלגוריתם ה-VQE שלנו תלויה מאוד
במצב וב-circuit
שאנחנו בוחרים להתחיל איתם.
אני Victoria Lipinska ובסרטון הזה
נחקור את האפשרויות
שיש לנו בעיצוב שלהם.
בואו נסתכל מקרוב
על כל האלמנטים
שיש לנו בכל הרצה של החלק הקוונטי
של ה-VQE.
אנחנו מתחילים עם מצב הייחוס,
שנקרא לפעמים מצב התחלתי.
אנחנו מריצים את מצב הייחוס
דרך circuit עם פרמטרים שנקרא
צורה וריאציונית
עם בחירה ראשונית של פרמטרים,
ואנחנו מודדים את המצב
בבסיס של ההמילטוניאן
אחרי שמריצים אותו דרך ה-circuit
כדי לקבל את ערך התוחלת. עכשיו
נעבור על כל אחד מהאלמנטים האלה,
ונתחיל עם מצב הייחוס.
בחירה טיפוסית למצב הייחוס
היא מצב האפס.
זה המצב שבו מחשב קוונטי
כבר מאותחל.
עבור בעיות כימיה קוונטית,
אפשר גם להשתמש במה שנקרא
מצב Hartree-Fock,
שהוא התוצאה של שיטת
Hartree-Fock.
בקצרה, תאוריית Hartree-Fock
נותנת דרך פשוטה לבנות
את מצב הייחוס על ידי קירוב
של מצב היסוד של מערכת קוונטית.
היא מוצאת סיבוב
בתוך מרחב המצבים
שממזער את אנרגיית מצב היסוד.
לבסוף, מצב הייחוס
יכול גם להיות מאוד ספציפי לבעיה,
ואולי תרצו לבחור
מצב מותאם אישית.
במקרה שאתם יודעים אילו תכונות
יש למערכת שלכם, למשל, סימטריות
או מספר ספציפי של אלקטרונים
במצב, אתם יכולים להשתמש בזה
כדי לקבל התכנסות טובה יותר של אלגוריתם
ה-VQE.
בחירת מצב ייחוס טוב
חשובה להתכנסות
מצבי ייחוס שקרובים
למצב היסוד
יכולים לגרום לבעיה להתכנס
הרבה יותר בקלות ובמהירות.
באותה מידה חשובה
הבחירה של ערכי הפרמטרים ההתחלתיים
שאנחנו מזינים לצורה הוריאציונית.
לכן, בהתאם למצב הייחוס
ולפרמטרים ההתחלתיים,
אנחנו עשויים להתכנס מהר, לאט
או לא להתכנס בכלל.
בואו נסתכל על הגרף הזה
ולצורך המחשה,
בואו נדמיין שלמרחב הפרמטרים שלנו
יש רק פרמטר אחד.
מצב ייחוס טוב מאוד
יכול לאפשר לכם להתחיל מאוד קרוב
למצב היסוד הסופי
ואז ההתכנסות תהיה מהירה.
מצד שני, אם אתם מתחילים מאוד רחוק
ממצב היסוד כאן,
מצב ייחוס
a, תצטרכו לחצות מחסום אנרגיה גבוה
שמוביל להתכנסות מאוד איטית
או בכלל בלי התכנסות.
נדון בזה לעומק יותר
במודול האופטימיזציה הקלאסית
בקורס הזה.
בואו עכשיו נסתכל על ה-circuit עם הפרמטרים
שפועל על מצב הייחוס, כלומר
הצורה הוריאציונית.
כשה-circuit הזה, ה-U של תטא,
פועל על מצב
הייחוס,
הוא מייצר מה שאנחנו קוראים מצב ניסיון
פסי של תטא או לפעמים אנזאץ.
את מצב האנזאץ הזה מודדים
אחר כך בבסיס מתאים
כדי לקבל ערך תוחלת
עבור האנרגיה.
הצורות הוריאציוניות
שאנחנו דנים בהן כאן
מונעות על ידי כימיה.
אבל, זכרו
שיש גם כאלה שמושרות
מלמידת מכונה קוונטית
ואלגוריתמים אחרים לטווח קרוב
כמו אלגוריתמים
לאופטימיזציה קוונטית מקורבת.
בואו נדון
בכמה בחירות נפוצות לאנזאץ כימי.
Unitary coupled cluster או UCC
היא השיטה שהוצעה במקור
בפרסום הראשון של VQE,
והיא נמצאת בשימוש נפוץ בבעיות
כימיה קוונטית.
בדרך כלל,
כשאנחנו מפרמטרים מצב קוונטי,
אנחנו עובדים עם מספר מעריכי
של פרמטרים.
אבל, כדי שמעגלי ההכנה
יהיו יעילים,
אנחנו צריכים מספר פולינומיאלי
של פעולות
ולכן מספר פולינומיאלי
של פרמטרים.
UCC היא דוגמה לדרך להכין
מצב ניסיון עם circuit כזה
והיא נגזרת משיטת
coupled cluster,
שהיא תקן הזהב בכימיה
קוונטית.
הבחירה הנפוצה ביותר היא unitary
coupled cluster
singles and doubles
אנזאץ או UCCSD בקיצור.
בגלל ש-UCCSD מונע על ידי קונפיגורציה
אלקטרונית ספציפית של בעיה,
אנחנו צריכים לוודא שיש לנו מצב ייחוס
שמשקף כראוי את המערכת.
זה מצב Hartree-Fock.
אנזאץ UCCSD בדרך כלל נותן
קירוב טוב של מצב היסוד
כי הוא לוכד עירורים של אלקטרון בודד
ושני אלקטרונים במולקולה נתונה.
מספר הפרמטרים ב-UCCSD גדל
באופן ריבועי עם מספר
אורביטלי הספין.
UCCSD יכול להיות מותאם
מאוד טוב לבעיה,
אבל לצערנו, סקיילינג ריבועי
עדיין מוביל ל-circuits עמוקים מאוד
שקשים למחשבים קוונטיים
של היום.
לכן חוקרים של IBM הציעו
גישה יותר היוריסטית,
שבה אפשר להתאים צורה וריאציונית
לחומרה הבסיסית
מה שמוביל ל-circuit
שניתן להריץ ביעילות.
כלומר, מצבי ניסיון מפורמטרים
על ידי gate קוונטיים
ומותאמים
להתקן הפיזי הזמין.
זו גישה מאוד היוריסטית
שידידותית לחומרה.
בהתבסס על הדוגמאות האלה, בואו נסתכל
על מגוון האפשרויות
שיש לנו לבטא
את הצורה הוריאציונית שלנו.
הרבה מהם כבר
מיושמים ב-Qiskit
אז אני מעודדת אתכם לנסות בעצמכם
איזה מהם הכי מתאים
לבעיה שאתם מנסים לפתור.
אם מסתכלים על הגרף, מצד אחד
יש לנו את הצורות הוריאציוניות
המאוד היוריסטיות.
כשהספציפיות לבעיה נמוכה, אבל
הן מתוכננות ליישום
על חומרה אמיתית.
הן גם מאוד אקספרסיביות,
במובן
שאפשר לבטא
הרבה מצבים קוונטיים איתן.
אבל,
בעיה שעלולה להתעורר בשלב
המאוחר יותר של אופטימיזציה
קלאסית היא להיתקל
במה שנקרא barren plateau,
שנדון בו במודול הבא.
מצד שני,
יש לנו unitary coupled cluster מאוד ספציפי לבעיה
שעובד מצוין בכימיה קלאסית אבל
קשה ליישום על חומרה קוונטית
בגלל עומקי circuit גדולים.
באופן כללי, חישובים
יכולים להצליח יותר אם אתם יכולים,
קודם כל לבחור מצב ייחוס
וסט התחלתי של פרמטרים
שיוצרים מצב אנזאץ
קרוב למצב היסוד.
ושנית, להימנע מפרמטרים מיותרים.
אלה או מוסיפים
עומק circuit גדול יותר בלי תועלת
או יוצרים מרחב פרמטרים גדול יותר
לחיפוש שמוביל לפלטו
באופטימיזציה הקלאסית.
אילו פרמטרים נחוצים זו שאלה
ספציפית לבעיה
שדורשת מחשבה זהירה.
בואו נדבר על איפה אורח הכבוד שלנו,
ההמילטוניאן, מסתתר בכל הסיפור הזה.
כפי שלמדנו בחלק הקודם,
ההמילטוניאן אחרי מיפוי qubit
מיוצג כסכום של
מחרוזות משוקללות של אופרטורי פאולי.
אבל בסופו של דבר,
אנחנו רוצים לחשב את ערך
התוחלת של ההמילטוניאן שלנו על מצב
האנזאץ שנוצר על ידי הצורה הוריאציונית.
למזלנו, מכניקת הקוונטים
היא נחמדה ולינארית
וזה מה שנשתמש בו
כדי לקבל את ערך התוחלת.
ככה זה עובד.
אנחנו יודעים שההמילטוניאן הוא סכום
משוקלל של פאולים
בגלל הלינאריות
ערך התוחלת של הסכום
שווה לסכום של ערכי
התוחלת של כל מחרוזת פאולי.
טוב, זה מעולה כי כפי שאתם כבר
יודעים, מדידה בבסיס פאולי
היא פשוטה כמו סיבוב
של בסיס מדידה סטנדרטי.
במקום למדוד את ערך התוחלת
על ההמילטוניאן העצום הזה שמיוצג
כסכום, אנחנו קודם מחשבים ערכי
תוחלת של איברים בודדים
וסוכמים בסוף
עם המשקולות המתאימים.
לכן במשאבים רבים
תראו רק סיבובי qubit בודד
אחרי האנזאץ.
זה מה שמממש את ההמילטוניאן
בכל הרצה של ה-circuit.
בסרטון הבא,
נחקור מה קורה
בשלב האופטימיזציה הקלאסית.
נתראה שם.